hi I'm Erik Bosse and Bladerunner 2049
is the new film everyone is talking
about a sequel to the 1982 sci-fi
classic now whether or not you've seen
the original Blade Runner you should
because it's amazing I don't like you
more we figured we could all use a
primer on the old Phil what is Blade
Runner why is it considered great what's
the deal with the multiple versions of
the film and how does it connect to the
new movie Blade Runner 2049 okay for the
uninitiated let's start with the basics
what is Blade Runner Blade Runner is a
sci-fi and more film directed by Ridley
Scott adapted from a philip k dick story
Do Androids Dream of Electric Sheep it
takes place in 2019 los angeles starring
Harrison Ford as Dekker a private
detective called a Blade Runner who
hunts down illegal rogue androids called
replicants that are for all purposes
identical to humans the film is super
moody and philosophical with different
versions that have caused fans to debate
over what exactly the film means so
here's where I cover our bases and warn
you that if you haven't seen the movie
it would probably be best to watch it
first but the problem with that is what
version of Blade Runner should you watch
okay I personally would say the 2007
Final Cut now I say that because it's
the only version that director Ridley
Scott had full artistic control over so
for me it makes it the truest - the
creators intent that's also by the way
the version in Blade Runner 2049
director at an evil new recommended to
watch that said the version that made
Blade Runner a huge influential hit in
the 80s a classic version most people
saw was the 1982 theatrical release you
could watch that to just know what was
later changed and why and final spoiler
warning here so in Blade Runner Deckard
hunts down a number of escaped
replicants in his pursuit he meets
Rachel an advanced new model of a
replicant who believes she's human she
has memories as a young girl that were
implanted in her mind later after
successfully tracking down and surviving
the other deadly replicant Deckard finds
this origami unicorn on the ground this
recalls the earlier line from the cop
baddie edward james olmos okay here's
where things change depending what
version you're watching the theatrical
cut added a happy ending after Deckard
and Rachel going to the elevator showing
them driving happily together with the
credits rolling over these bright aerial
shots and some new
awkward narration from Harrison Ford
tyrella told me Rachel was special no
termination date I didn't know how long
we'd have together who does the studio
actually added lots of other narration
from Harrison Ford along with an
explanatory opening crawl and this happy
ending all to clarify and contextualize
the film after test audiences found an
earlier version in their words confusing
and I said the studio because yeah this
was not something Ridley Scott wanted to
do these aerial shots were actually
given to the film by Stanley Kubrick
they were unused shots from The Shining
some have even suggested that Ford acted
the new narration poorly on purpose even
though he denies everyone fill the film
in this version became a cult classic
but years later someone discovered an
old film print of a different kind of
the movie with Ridley Scott's approval
they assembled a 1992 director's cut
which removed Deckard's narration ended
the movie with the elevator door closing
and inserted this earlier decker
daydream featuring a unicorn running
through a forest this shot gave a whole
new meaning to the end of the film the
unicorn origami that Deckard finds
presumably left by Gaddy is a reference
to a vision that is only in Deckard's
mind so the fact that someone else knew
about this unicorn and left him this
little tot suggests that Deckard's
memories were implanted and that he too
is a replicant Ridley Scott has
confirmed this interpretation of the
film's ending and it's 2007 final cut
keeps all these key changes in place now
Blade Runner 2049 it's supposed to give
us new insights about who or what
Deckard is now it won't be spoiling the
movie in this video to be honest I
haven't seen the movie yet but it's fair
to say that the ending of Blade Runner
regardless of what version you saw is
meant to be ambiguous that mystery over
what makes us human is really the
central premise of the film so let's
quickly discuss what does Blade Runner
mean so the film opens with this
interview called a voight-kampff test
it's the personality test blade runner's
give suspected replicants to determine
whether or not they're human now this is
based on the real-life Turing test where
you test a computer to see if they can
exhibit true artificial intelligence now
the whole film of Blade Runner is
essentially an extended void camp test
Deckard is tested to prove his humanity
to us as other replicants suffer and die
around him he
discovers that they are in many ways
more human than we are quite an
experience to live in fear isn't it
that's what it is to be a slave and the
very uncertainty that Deckard might be a
replicant gives us the film's verdict on
artificial intelligence in humanity what
does it matter if we can't tell the
difference the fact that not all of us
are 100% on what this ending is means
that the Turing test has been passed now
that theme has been hugely influential
on the sci-fi film genre ever since
recently things like Westworld and ex
machina clearly have Blade Runner in
their DNA's and it's not just the
philosophy of the movie the look and
aesthetics of it's grimy futuristic war
production design inspired the design of
things like The Matrix ghost in the
shell' The Fifth Element Children of Men
the reboot of Battlestar Galactica and
given how much Hollywood loves Blade
Runner it's no surprise that the
franchise has been brought back to life
so what should we expect from Blade
Runner 2049 now it's important to know
that even though this is a sequel this
isn't so much a blatant Hollywood cash
grab that sequels are known to be the
director is denn evil move a visual
genius behind the thoughtful patient
films like a rival Sicario and prisoners
an arrival in particular he crafted a
sci-fi mystery with subtle visual clues
that converged like puzzle pieces all at
a precise moment this guy deeply
understands what Ridley Scott was aiming
to do with Blade Runner and he's not a
fan of excessive dialogue so don't
expect any narration but that's exactly
why casting Ryan Gosling as the new
Blade Runner K was so perfect Gosselin
gives up this quiet steely nerves seeing
the movies like dry his toughness is
actually very similar to Harrison Ford's
in the 80s a cold exterior protecting a
soft a boyish sensitivity so to see
these two men share the screen together
is really exciting it's almost like two
editions of a toy trying to out Moody
each other what happens to the new model
when an old model comes back I'll show
you a haunted kid which version of Blade
Runner do you think is the best to watch
as we prepare for a 2049 weigh in in the
comments below or tweet me at EA boss or
follow new rockstars at new rockstars
for updates on our videos like this
video and subscribe to new rockstars for
more deep dives into the films you love
and yeah keep an eye out for our review
of Blade Runner 2049 all right thanks
for watching bye